اه طبعا في مواقع كثيره لكن هو المشكله
مواقع استطاعت ان تكذب ناس كثير مرموقين
كتاب وادباء ويستطيع كتابه القصه الصحفيه
امر لن يزول كما ان سلوك البيع والشراء لن
يزول من البشر وان اختلفت وسائله كذلك
الصحافه انا سؤالي في المجال المصري عريقه
في هذا المجال وفي هذا يعني رائده في
الصحافه العربيه هل هي ايضا انتجت صيغ
جديده
دي هي عندنا المواقع الالكترونيه المواقع
الالكترونيه عندنا دلوقت بدات تاخذ وتسحب
من قارئ الصحيفه اليوم اكثر ماشي بس هل
الصح هل المواقع الالكترونيه قيمه تتبع
الصحف عن هذا السؤال مثلا خلينا نعطيك
مثال واضح الاهرام الاخبار
الوفد الرجل يوسف الصحف المعروفه هذه
والصحف
تصور ان المصداقيه في هذه المواقع اه
لماذا تتصور ان المصداقيه مرتبطه بهذه
الاسماء التي كانت موجوده لا ميعاد يعني
اذا قلنا ال- انه فكره الشغف لم تعد
موجوده زي ما كان بيتقال دلوقتي بدل هذه
المؤسسات الصحفيه الكبيره فبالتالي اصبح
الوجه الاخر لمواقعها هي انها تنقل ما نشر
في الصفحه ال- الصفحات يعني لا هذا يقدم
قصه ولا هذا لا يقدم قصه انما انا باقول
لك ان الخارج الان من عباءه هذا يستطيع ان
يقدم الجديد